clothing is a popular item on many
holiday shopping list but some fashion
companies want shoppers to buy fewer
clothes in order to cut pollution the
average person buys 60% more clothing
today than they did 18 years ago
researchers estimate the fashion
industry will use 25% of the world's
carbon budget by 2050 that's estimated
amount of carbon dioxide emissions that
the planet can have without the worst
effects of climate change Elaine Quijano
of our streaming network cbsn is inside
and Eileen Fisher store or they're doing
something about that
Elain good morning good morning to you
you know it's easy to get caught up in
the holiday shopping season but
statistics show that holding on to
clothing an average of nine months
longer can actually reduce the carbon
footprint by twenty to thirty percent
and that is something that designer
Eileen Fisher thinks about a lot so we
keep everything and now we're making
like amazing pieces of art out of scraps
at a tiny factory in Irvington New York
they're deconstructing the Eileen Fisher
is small but mighty team of socially
conscious employees are trying to make a
dent in fashions carbon footprint they
get between four and six thousand aces a
week four and six thousand rise a week
the renew program buys back worn Eileen
Fisher pieces and sorts them to
determine if they can be resold resewn
this was a hole they made it part of the
design or remade this is made from about
twenty old sweaters we see it as an
important long term investment for us
it's a bit hard to rationalize that cost
we do it because we think it's the right
thing to do and because we believe
there's going to be no business done on
a dead planet so hopefully better do the
best we can fashion accounts for nearly
ten percent of greenhouse gas emissions
and 85 percent of unwanted clothing ends
up in landfills like this one
Eiling up to more than 12 million tons
annually when you think about the
magnitude does it ever seem overwhelming
for yes oh it's daunting it's yeah some
days I try not to get depressed some
days I say oh my god it feels like we're
moving deck chairs on the Titanic just
like how many more years do we have
twelve before catastrophe strikes us
we're only a drop in the bucket and
we're trying to role model for other
companies other companies have tapped
into the sustainable market too like
Patagonia who's Warren ware program
encourages customers to patch up old
clothing rather than buy new even IKEA
is testing a program to buy back their
old furniture and hmm offers a recycling
program where customers get 15% off when
they bring in used items but
sustainability expert Maxine B doc says
coupons just encourage more consumption
and only about one out of every thousand
pieces sold is ever recycled the last
figures that have come in are showing
that there are a hundred and fifty
billion new pieces of clothing that are
made every single year if you look even
at the global population that's a
disposable wardrobe for every man woman
and child on the planet every single
year I tend to favor natural material
over synthetics you can see things are
pulling she says consumers need to be
more conscious shoppers you don't have
to be wealthy to make these sustainable
choice exactly you can learn a lot from
the clothes just from looking at the tag
and looking at the inside of the garment
and I think that's the takeaway it's not
about you know getting a PhD in
sustainability it's about finding the
clothes that we really love and only
using our hard-earned money to purchase
things that we're really gonna want to
wear in the future and Eileen Fisher's
renew program has sold nearly 3 million
dollars worth of garments that would
have otherwise ended up in landfills and
finding ways to reuse versus throwing
away unwanted clothing can actually save
taxpayer dollars in New York City alone
it costs eighty five million dollars
each year
collect and dispose of unwanted clothing
John thank you no good for the planet
and good for the budget thank you